hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the second
day so the last day of the uh tournament
with the weirdest name ever the gold
money asian rapid knockouts it's levon
aaron
versus vladislav the two finalists and
levon won the first match yesterday and
now artemiev needs to bounce back
in the rapid section to force tie breaks
uh he needs to get it to the blitz games
and then
uh if nothing happens in the blitz
section then they go into armageddon and
so levon
basically what he needs from the second
match is to
tie the match he he doesn't need to win
the match and he already won game one
this game that we're showing is game two
and it's uh it's really an incredible
game you guys are going to enjoy it so
without further ado let's check it out
levon with the white pieces
on this great sunday opens with d4
we have g6 going for the modern defense
we have e4 by levon
now shifting with to just a normal
uh basically the same as if you would
play uh e4 g6 and then d4 so just
claiming the center
much like our good friend morphy would
we have bishop to g7
and knight to f3 now we have d6 and now
c3 strengthening the center going for
the so-called geller system
we have knight to f6 and now bishop to
d3 so
nicely going for some rapid development
we have castles uh castles by both sides
uh and now c5 artemia strikes in the
center as that's what you have to do
when your opponent has a massive center
such as this one
we have h3 by lavon preventing this
bishop from being developed to a
very active square and now queen to c7
and up until this point this is all
uh theory it has all been played before
we have e5 uh sorry rook to e1
just developing the rook black replies
with e5 uh with
a double attack on the center here uh
and bishop to
e3 now so levon just continues
development we have b6 now preparing to
uh
develop the light square bishop and
knight b to d2 the knight is now coming
to f1
then in the future you can come to g3
you can come to e3 you can maybe come to
h2 and then g4 if needed so the knight
on f1 is very very nicely placed
and also in some lines it can even be
used as a defender
to the to the white king so knight to c6
and
now there is one game in the database
where a3 was played but here
that we have ripped the c1 aligning the
rook nicely with the queen on c7
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
artemis
continues we have rooked the e8 he
continues development
but one thing you have to notice is that
the light square bishop still hasn't
been developed and the rooks are not
connected and you should always uh
uh strive towards connecting your rooks
uh levons rooks still aren't connected
yet
but uh we'll see what happens so d5 now
attacking this knight grabbing more
space in the center
knight to e7 and now b4 and here
you don't really want to capture if you
capture it makes really no sense
capturing with a
uh you know more central pawn uh to the
left central uh
central pawn and here you would just get
some like queen b8 queen c2 and the
white now has complete control of the c
file so instead after b4 just knight to
d7
now you even might have some ideas of
executing f5 in the future
and now knight to f1 continuing as
planned we have bishop
we have c4 now uh challenging the light
square bishop the bishop back to c2
and now f5 so artemiev has to go
very aggressive because he's down a
point in the match and he has to win
this match in order to force tie breaks
uh we have e captures by levon and now
uh knight captures on f5
is what you would play if you were not
down a point in the match but here
artemiev says
let's be real uh this looks way cooler
he plays g captures on f5
and now he also has a massive center and
now he can start advancing e4
f4 uh depending on what levon plays so
here we have bishop to g5 not allowing
f4 to close down this
bishop here so bishop to g5 and now e4
attacking the knight here and now an
excellent square by lavon and this is a
great opportunity for those of you who
are maybe new to chess to
realize that when someone attacks your
uh piece and here
he's attacking it with a pawn upon is
valued much less than a knight uh some
say that a pawn is valid
one and maybe a knight is valued three
uh but you don't wanna just move the
knight automatically because it's been
attacked maybe there's something
else that you can play and often
beginners have a hard time
realizing this incredible truth so here
levon plays
knight to g3 and now he says all right
you can capture my knight because then
your knight on e7 is attacked twice and
here artemyev says
yeah but that doesn't really help you
all that much i'm just gonna play e
captures on f3
and now what do you play well you guys
are uh here to help us with that feel
free to pause the video and help
levon win this final match while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not
trying to immediately restore the
material balance and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on f5 and this
definitely makes sense now there's a
triple attack on the knight here and
also if you just capture here then the
rook falls the rook on e8 is undefended
and like i said the bishop still has not
been developed the rooks are not
connected and that can be a problem and
here
this entire line for white basically uh
came to fruition because the rooks are
not connected and
just to show you what happens if you
immediately go to restore material
balance
for example if you go rook captures on
e7 rook captures and bishop captures
then
black has this very nasty knight the e5
move
uh that attacks the bishop here and also
now defends the f3 square and now after
you move the
bishop you can just play some like queen
f7 and the position is really really
good for black because now if you want
to recapture you have to mess up your
pawn structure and then it's it looks
very ugly for white
so instead after he captures an f3 level
of course uh continued in great style he
played knight captures on f5
and now we have knight to e5 of course
you cannot
capture this because white will first
capture the rook with check
so knight captures on e5 on f5
is not possible so knight to e5 and now
comes
knight captures on g7 this is uh
incredible chess by levon king captures
on e7 and now
even rook captures on e5 this entire
series of moves is the only winning line
for white so levon playing incredible
rapid chess here
d captures an e5 and now d6 that's
that's the good stuff
we have queen to d7 the queen has the
side step and only now
not gaining material back but first
queen captures on f3 levon just going uh
all out to to impress us all like i said
on this
great sunday the rook now hangs also the
knight is still under attack so you
don't really have
uh ways of defending this you might try
something like knight to c6 which
definitely makes sense uh because now
both of your pieces are defended
but then we just throw in a nice bishop
to f6 check and now the queen and the
bishop
pair will be uh well just just
unstoppable king to g8 we're going to
play bishop to e4
now with a double attack on the knight
here and once this
knight is let's say defended now we play
bishop to d5 check
and now the bishops and the queen are
just um
well too strong here not much for you to
do if you move the king
just bishop to e7 check king to g7 and
now queen to f6 will be checkmate
so not a lot of options here uh so uh
after this uh
queen captures an f3 move uh you can't
play knight to c6 what you could play is
maybe rook to b8 just sidestep with the
rook but it
runs into the pretty much same idea
queen f6 check
a much shorter one king to g8 now bishop
captures an h7 check we can even
sacrifice the bishop here
king captures queen f7 check and now the
king has only one square king to h8 and
now bishop to f6
will be checkmate so what can artemis do
here
well after this uh uh e
uh after this uh knight captures an f uh
after this
uh queen captures an f3 move uh he can
well just uh try and give back the
material so he plays knight to g6 and
now levon
again not going for the material right
away uh first uh he plays uh
sorry uh here he he actually went for
material uh he's been uh
not going for material for so long that
i thought he he's gonna do something
else here but here he did capture the
rook so queen captures on a8
we have bishop to b7 and now how do you
save the white queen the white queen
seems to be getting trapped
we have queen captures on a7 and now
queen to c6 defending the
escape square and now levon says nope
that's not a problem i'm not worried
about rook to a8 i'm just going to play
f3 and you have to play this you can't
just play anything because checkmate is
being threatened
so f3 and now we reach the position from
the thumbnail it seems like levon's
queen is uh
well trapped but not really because i
would ask you guys to pause the video
here but you already saw the thumbnail
so queen the a8 was played
attacking levon's queen but now lemon
says uh not a problem i'm just gonna
play
d7 and now if you capture my queen which
is possible i'm just gonna bring another
queen into the game and now
well i'm still just much better my my
position is better i'm up material
uh if you if you go after my queen i'm
just gonna bring the queen back this is
this is not a problem even if rook
captures on a2 uh just
bishop to h6 check and it's a really
ugly position for
for black if king the g8 we're just
going to play queen to d8 to check
and slowly go after the black king king
f7 we're gonna go rook to d1 go here
there's no defending this position so
after d7
we have queen captures on d7 but now the
queen left the defense of the b6 spawn
so queen captures on b6 and not rook to
a6 by artemia we have queen back to e3
and now rook captures an a2 artemia has
to win back some material otherwise his
position is completely hopeless
so here we have rook to d1 leaving the
bishop undefended because the queen is
now under attack so queen to e6
and now queen to c5 again levon leaves
the bishop undefended he wants to
deliver this check
but even this is not uh simple as it
seems because after rook captures on c2
we have queen to c7 check
and now you can't block with the queen
because there is bishop to h6 check
and this would just uh win the queen if
we capture here then the queen is lost
and if we go king to g8 then just rook
d8 to check
and now again an incredible line knight
to f8 and now queen captures on c4 levon
could even sacrifice the queen here
if you do nothing then just rook
captures this is game over this will be
checkmate because the queen cannot move
it's pinned
and of course if you capture the queen
then rook captures an f8
beautiful checkmate so uh levon just uh
really crushing this finals in great
style so king the g8
uh moving out of check this way but now
just recapturing the bishop
so queen captures on b7 we have knights
the f8
but now rook to d8 level not afraid of
leaving the back rank because there's a
pawn here on a dark square so you don't
have to worry about
the black queen gaining control of this
diagonal so rook captures on c3 but now
bishop to e7 the simplest way to end
things because now the knight will fall
we rook the c1 check now comes king to
h2 and he was in this position on move
36 that uh vladislav
have resigned the game and levon arunyan
is the winner of the gold money asian
rapid tournament uh an event with the
weirdest name ever
uh and uh well it's just an incredible
incredible feat that he achieved here he
he not only defeated incredibly strong
players but he also did it in great
style
as you've seen in this game how he
played against the the incredible
chuck norris here uh so here you resign
as there's no defense against
rook captures on e7 it's just
unstoppable uh
and other than that there's no there
there's not a move that
even can make a little bit of problems
for white so
it's just instant resign uh so yeah
levon wins game one of the final match
also game two and now even if la isla
won the two
uh two games that will follow it's still
gonna be a tie to two to two
and then uh lebron since he won the
first match he's gonna be the winner so
that's all
only two games so in in the final day uh
so congratulations to levon on this uh
amazing achievement and it seems that uh
the the armenian lion is is definitely
back and here
he he is he is here to stay uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh
incredible clash in the finals so we're
also going to check out the other match
ding versus magnus
so stay tuned for that uh i would like
to thank james walker peter milner
wolfgang schmidt
simon surveilla and bruce b buckley for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the this
event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday